Raphaël n'est pas encore censé être né
c'est un extrême prématuré les bébés
peuvent survivre à 24 23 des fois mais
c'est en bas de ça puis on sait pas avec
quelle qualité de vie vont avoir aussi
hospitaliser à partir de 10 semaines de
grossesse à cause d'une condition rare
Nathalie Nicolas a accouché par
césarienne d'urgence à 25 semaines
Raphaël pesait alors 600 grammes moi je
ressens ça comme un échec parce que j'ai
pas réussi à porter la grossesse à terme
j'ai pas réussi à donner tout ce que je
pouvais pour mon bébé et que c'est sûr
que c'était si un coup dur beaucoup
d'émotion
puis vient l'impuissance face à
l'angoisse et le stress de savoir s'il
va s'en sortir
il est attaché de partout puis c'est dur
comme parent
mesurer la respiration la pression
sanguine le rythme cardiaque les
nouveaux-nés prématurés peuvent être
branchés à une dizaine de fils c'est le
système sans fil donc ce sont deux
capteurs c'est justement pour réduire le
stress l'encombrement et les risques
d'infection que des chercheurs de
l'hôpital pour enfants de Montréal
étudier des premiers moniteurs de
synvito portable et intelligent en plus
de ça vous allez pouvoir avoir des
renseignements supplémentaires par
exemple sur le mouvement du bébé avec un
capteur sur la poitrine l'autre sur le
pied les informations peuvent être
transmises à un moniteur intelligent à
l’extérieur de la chambre ce qui
permettra aussi de minimiser les sons la
prochaine partie c'est vraiment de
s'assurer que ça peut se faire
sécuritairement dans un système
hospitalier ou les erreurs ne peuvent
pas se permettre il faut pas avoir par
exemple un milieu où il y a pas de
réseau sans fil l'autonomie des
batteries peut aller jusqu'à 24 heures
les capteurs intelligents pourraient
donc aussi permettre éventuellement au
bébé de rentrer plus vite à la maison
parce qu'on pourra faire la télémétrie
puis la télésurveillance de ses bébés là
qui sont quidama fragiles pendant un bon
bout de temps plus rapidement à domicile
donc c'est un projet très important en
termes de qualité de vie c'est un peu
pour cette raison que Nathalie Nicolas a
participé à la première phase de l'étude
ça sera jamais la normalité mais on peut
se rapprocher de la normalité puisque ça
aide comme coeur de parents
attendre encore des années avant de voir
l'hôpital intelligent à plus large
échelle ici Jacques au Canada Montréal